just as the first minister of scotland
had her second
jab she had another one for the mayor of
greater manchester
i have always gone well with andy
burnham if he wants a grown-up
conversation
he only has to pick up the phone i think
nicholas students saying i should pick
up the phone well i'm
more than happy to but shouldn't they
have picked up the phone before they
before they they did this i have a duty
it's one i take very seriously to keep
scotland as safe as possible i'm sure
andy burnham feels
that same sense of duty towards people
in the greater manchester
area bolton has a significantly lower
case rate
than dundee bolton is under this travel
ban
dundee is not so i think we need an
explanation from the scottish government
dundee does have comparable rates with
manchester salford
bolton and blackburn it's only those
places in the northwest of england
that now have a non-essential travel ban
to and from scotland
up to 20 000 members of the tartan army
headed for central london last friday
and could have met anyone the bus tour
operators like robert in south
manchester
another part of his business recovery
plan has been snatched away
it's just more frustration after more
frustration the lack of help
we've been having over the last 15
months
and then to have to start planning to do
something again and
think about things again it feels like
having your teeth pulled out
the mayor was launching a clean air zone
for greater manchester today
but he's not letting this row with the
scottish government go
quite often nicola sturgeon and andy
burnham are on the same side of the
fence both
criticizing the westminster government's
handling of the pandemic
to have them now going at each other
maybe novel
but it probably isn't helping anyone
manchester is a city where people have
always
held firm in their beliefs deeds
not words but that idea spreads far
beyond
borders tom parmenter sky news
manchester